i remember that day like yesterday i
turned off my computer and i said
okay guys trust me i'm going to hire you
and fire you i promise
that was like almost two years ago and
after that time i didn't send any
any application for job
[Music]
thank you for joining me all the way
from serbia to 20-minute leaders it's so
great to have you
it's really great having you here can
you hear me hello hello
hello michael nice to meet you wonderful
nice to meet you and nice to hear you
yes
every time i'm exciting when i have to
talk with you
actually because of your beautiful
energy
i i love that thank you so much for
saying that i i just love the energy
that you're exuding and
and i can't wait to know all about you
in these next 20 minutes or so so
sonia can you please just go back and
tell me a little bit of what you're
doing in serbia
where you come from and and later on
we'll get into the whole
united arab emirates interaction and
your work with the government and
different companies
but first who is sonia uh sanyo lowatsky
uh sanjaya lovato is coming from serbia
yes
i'm coming from uh i'm living in
belgrade uh
at the moment uh actually i'm between uh
serbia
and united arab emirates uh actually
between uh belgrade and dubai
or abu dhabi or sharjah or russell
i'm coming from one small city from
serbia
called crucifix it's a one hour and a
half drive from uh
from belgrade and one of the most famous
city
actually from from serbia
i'm 36 years old and
my story it's probably very interesting
story uh because it's really hard to
connect
uh uae serbia
united states europe you know especially
when you're coming from small city
uh well like me uh but uh
what brings me there is uh my
dream actually and uh
first time when i came to uae to be
honest uh
i fall in love with uh with people
with country uh because it's totally
different
and uh before that i had a chance to
travel a lot uh
i had a chance to uh finish my high
school
united states i came here i was
16 and i finished in my high school
in oklahoma yes in oklahoma
i went to new york then i went to
oklahoma and
i i have beautiful experience from from
united states and
i learned a lot um united states
actually helped me to
shift me actually to to be who i am
today
uh and i'm trying to explain to
to people in europe that uh uh
it's the best way to find yourself it's
to go to united states when you're uh
young uh especially when you're coming
from
europe southeast europe like me
because uh it's a different business
culture it's a different
lifestyle uh when i was there like
uh more than 20 years ago um
i learned that i learned one thing
during that time that
if you are uh confident if you
uh want to learn if you want to fight
for yourself and for your dream you're
going to achieve this
there is no someone who is going to stop
you
during your journey or when you're on
your way
and uh if you are hard worker
you are going to achieve whatever you
want this is what i learned
that time i don't know how it's going to
the moment but
during that time was really exciting and
uh
especially when you're coming from
serbia you know i was like uh
i was so interesting for for people from
usa but when i finished my high school
there
i continued my studies and i
went to european university and i
finished my
my degree in business relations and
marketing
uh but before that i wanted to study so
much
so so so bad i wanted to study a
dramatic art
but uh yes and that time
i was something between business and
dramatic arts you know because i was
playing
uh classical ballet from uh for 13 years
i was so much involved in art you know
and
uh it was my my dream actually i wanted
to follow my dream and be someone
uh poison will be someone who is
successful you know
in culture and art industry uh but
especially in southeast europe uh it's
not
a kind of uh very well paid job
so i talked to my parents you know one
day and
with my mom and she said like okay if
you
want to have us your whole life to pay
your bills and bring your food every day
go on you know be someone who is working
in culture industry so
just do it and i decided yes yes
it's true and it still is the same you
know uh
uh never mind you if you're in uh serbia
or
or uh uh in any part of europe uh and
artists they they know it
it's really hard to survive can you
imagine how it's hard to ride during the
covet
at the moment for them so uh i said okay
no it's not disturbing
it's hard to survive also in new york as
an artist and in israel as an artist
everywhere in the world
it's right it's it's a passion that
doesn't always pay as much as you would
hope and
there's a long tail there's a few people
that make a lot but there's a really
long tale of people
who make very little and are just trying
to get by yes yes yes you're right but
i decided i i had one
big conversation with myself to be
honest and said to myself okay okay girl
you like shoes you like bags you like to
dress well
so are you sure that you want to study
dramatic arts
so or you want to be a business lady
so i decided well i'm going to be a
business lady and i'm going to be
successful business lady not just one
business lady you know
uh then uh after yes after mine um
after my uh graduation uh i i i want to
mention this that i finished uh
fourth year uh in two year and eight
months
because i was thinking
that is the best time for to to running
for money
and to uh to to get as fast as i can
shoes brands everything you know and
i finished my my university earlier than
other students and i continued my
education and i finished my master's
degree
also uh in business relation and
marketing and
at that time i was the uh youngest
holder of master degree i was uh
20 22 actually
almost 23 with master degree yes
but as i said my my big
dream was to be involved in art
so i decided to go
and finish my
postmaster degree in dramatic arts
and to make my dream come true and to
show my family yes
i made it but i can
i can pay my food as you see you know
but i i'm going to make this
so i finished my post-graduation studies
uh which is between master degree and
phd
so uh i i finished audi and visual
uh dramatic and audio visual arts
and i need the moment uh one year and a
half to
to be a a phd but
i'm not interested to be honest to stay
and work in university i'm more business
person
so i decided later to to continue
with the executive education because
it's
more familiar familiar with me
uh and with the business and that's what
you're doing today with the
uc berkeley yes uh yes this is
why i i want to uh i would like to make
a point about this uh
in the end when we start to talk about
the uae and during that time
yes i have extensive experience i was in
business i was in business development
in marketing
in media uh printing media you know
uh in the last 15 years actually but
uh one one day when when i came to
to uae as a visitor actually uh i had a
chance to
to go uh there early because my uh
my very close relatives are there like
in last
20 years and they invited me so many
times
very successful family there from serbia
and uh
they invited me so many times but i was
like okay now
i won't like to finish my master i would
like to finish my postmaster degree i
want to travel
next time next year you know and five
years ago
actually right yes five years ago um
i went there finally and
when i came there i realized
that i have all in one in dubai
uh i had a chance to see on the left
side
london new york chicago
and on the other side i can see whole
europe
and i totally disagree with the
the stereotypes that the uae copied
everything i'm just thinking that
they are at the moment uh and they're
going to be
uh definitely global leader
uh in innovation and
in business and they're really
uh amazing first first of all
uh as a people uh as a nation
and we need to learn from them
a lot uh yes
what i want to mention uh but i forgot
what was important
important during the my youngest age
that
uh because we are talking a lot about
the
self-confidence now self-confidence
self-respect
self-grow you know everything is
becoming like self-selfish no but
it's not i think that we need to think
in that way um
first book that i had chance to read
during that time like 50 like 20
uh 20 years ago when i was like 15.
and that was really hard to find a book
uh to read about it
read about the self-confidence and to
learn
that it's okay to say no it's okay to
say yes
and it's okay to ask uh
to join me or to help me but during that
time
you were young you can't remember was
really
uncomfortable to say that uh you this is
your life and this
is your choice and you're going to
follow your dreams
and fight for it you know it's it's a
different it was different because
during that time we were talking about
globalization and we were so scared
about globalization oh my god
uh we are going to look the same
everything is going to be the same you
know
like european union should be joined or
not
competitive or not so uh uh first book
that i had a chance to read was uh
anthony demelo uh wake up
and uh that was i think one of the first
books
uh that you can find uh and read about
it and uh when i was 16 and i said okay
i'm reading this and recommend this book
to my
relatives my family my friends they
started to
to look at me and ask am i okay is
something
wrong why i'm reading this yes yes it's
true
you know because from this region you
know
we are leading we're reading uh uh
of course we're reading a world famous
writer but
more familiar with chekhov you know read
poems or something but not
not about self-confidence and you're
guys so lucky
that you have a chance to choose
to be or to do whatever you want
and live you can't imagine uh
how how it's easy for you
to survive today if when i compare
how was how it's hard how was hard for
me
to survive like 15 years ago
but let's uh let's go back on
uae yes i wanted to to move there uh
so bad but uh so
unlucky to move i was someone
who had amazing city really
with the recommendations and
extensive experience and i was
you know like so educated everything
that i
that i uh that you need to to have like
if you want to move
to the market because uh for example
uh you have uh like 200
000 uh arabs in dubai but you
have uh around two million people uh
as experts uh so uh i was thinking the
time
right how i'm not i was asking myself
well uh
i'm not competitive enough to go to the
market because you know
uh coming from uh europe uh
so educated smart pretty you know as
well so
it's just easy for me to come go there
but
uh no i sent and i told you this
uh first time when we had a chance to
talk
i applied uh i spent i think
more than 500 uh
500 applications to to
to get the job and i didn't
had a chance to get any kind of
interview
i wrote so many messages on linkedin uh
uh i think the right hr people
uh directors uh and uh
99 of them uh was coming
from europe uh
and the worst thing is that i never get
any kind of
answer from them like you're not good
enough or
just uh we will discuss or thank you you
know just be polite with me but
no and as i said as the one who is very
very self-confident
and uh someone who who don't want to
accept
noah's and answer
i was so i was so mad i was so mad on
myself and i was so mad on that people
and one day i said
okay guys this is not gonna work i sent
more than 500
applications and i'm going to quit now
wow but do you know what 500
yes i can send you i can send you
because you know i think 530 something
yes
it's ridiculous and i was so mad i was
thinking
okay let's do the other thing i turn it
off my computer
i remember that day like yesterday i
turned off my computer and i said
okay guys trust me i'm going to hire you
and fire you i promise
that was like almost two years ago
and after that time i didn't send any uh
any application for job uh
i was thinking and this is the what your
audience
need to learn because we are talking
about young people
this is the time when you uh
we're living in a time when you don't
have a time to be
disappointed you can be whatever you
want to be
but you don't have a time to be
disappointed i'm not telling you like
uh follow your dreams fight for them
it's not going to be easy it's going to
be hard
but you need to be confident about
yourself
and to know what's the difference
between
you and the other person what you can
bring to the table
what you can serve what is the
the best about you and uh you really
need to talk a lot
with yourself i'm someone who is a
overthinker i can say and and i talk a
lot with myself because
um you you you need to learn from your
own mistakes
because uh every fail is not a
fail if you if it's not a lesson
actually
and uh when i said okay
i send it 500 times it's not gonna work
what i can do
uh during that time i didn't have a
chance uh
to be honest to talk with uh with with
uh arab guys
because in the arab people because you
know
uh it's really hard to to to uh
to get the conversation with with them
because you have so much experts you
know
uh on you have so much experts to talk
uh and you you are going to be rejected
because
it's normal they are just scared about
their position
and uh i was thinking okay what they can
offer
that is a different so uh
that how this is going to help me to to
to make my dream come true and
make this story short uh i was the first
lady because as i'm talking i was
talking about my
dramatic arts i was the first lady
from this country and
probably i'm not sure but for sure from
ex yugoslavia because we are
ex-yugoslavian country
i was first lady who was
approved from uae government
to make uh and filming first movie
between uh uae and serbia
uh igot is a co-producer one of the
famous guy who is uh
who is my friend actually now uh very
very close friend but one of the most
famous guy
from there and i got
that approval i been recommend from the
uae government
and been recommend my project to to
proceed as fast as they can
and make this come true at the moment
because of coming
covered and everything we we we start
with that project but
during that time i realized that what i
need to do
is to build my connection
and my networking this is especially for
yui
this is the most important thing but the
other important thing
is we have totally
totally different pictures picture about
them
uh we're thinking oh my god
low carbs banking machine
is coming to us and i'm trying to
explain this to
people especially in in europe because
we we
are following that kind of stereotypes
that
uh uh arabs uh are going to finance
everything
uh people think okay we are going to
take money from
them for this project for that project
uh this is the the
the the the biggest the biggest problem
about the uh above about people about
what they think about
uh arabs uh i swear
uh that at the moment
and uh like ten years and fifteen years
ago
uh united arab emirates in in
uh people they're coming from uae
uh are people who uh still
know the real value of business
of life of families
or friendship when you
yes because the most important thing
about them is they need
to to meet you they need to
understand you you need to understand
them uh they respect
trust they respect loyalty they are
they are ready to invest in your project
they are ready to listen
but first what you need to learn
is to sit with them
to learn about them to learn about their
history to learn about their family to
learn about
business culture because it's totally
different than other country
that other culture in whole world uh we
are so much focused
to learn about uh especially here in
europe
to learn about uh china
about russia about america uh and uh
we never had a chance to learn how
things
function in uae uh because it's
it's totally different and uh
back to my to my movie uh and i started
to build my
connection today i can say that uh
i have one uh extensive
uh uh extensive book big book of
connections
uh with the with the top management
people coming from uae arabic people
and they recognize from your eyes
trust me when you come there with your
heart
to make this uh uh to make this
huge with them or if you are just coming
there to
to live for a few years and take money
and move they just understand that they
can feel that
and you when you're there and when you
have a chance to sit and talk with them
trust me
you don't need any kind of uh life coach
because uh each of them each of arabs
can be our teacher can be a teacher
for entire world they build
everything from nothing this country
show us that nothing is impossible
during the covet uh in july if you
remember
they had a mission to mars
so uh in when when everything
fell they had a chance to grow
and this is the reason why i'm saying
they're going to become a global reader
very soon in any kind of of uh
in industry yes and
to go back to uh yes to go back to
my uh live journey and my famous
sentence
when i said i'm going to hire you and
fire you
uh a few months ago
i was working on my project
movie project and during that time also
i was a new business director in one
big company here uh i got one call
and uh was really surprising for me
uh because the the gentleman
said uh we are calling you
uh about potential position to be
executive director of uh one
amazing project and uh to be honest
you've been
uh recommend from uh
abu dhabi from uh business people from
from uae and i said okay
let's see what what is about
uh now i'm working
as executive director of
uh united arab emirates in serbia
business club
uh which is uh yes which is uh
uh established by embassy of
uae in serbia and
the most famous companies coming from
ue investors uh actually
they're here in serbia uh when i say big
names
i'm talking about investments
from uh etihad from budala
from al dhakra yash holding
eagle hills so
you can imagine uh what kind of
companies
i'm talking about uh and uh
that companies uh are my board members
my um chairman is coming from mirabank
which is hundred percent owned from uh
royal group uh abu dhabi and uh
finally uh i can say that i
i have a job i'm just
living my dream that
i'm just living my dream to be connect
uh with the right people
with the right people uh i mean uh
someone who is uh who
who knows to respect hard work
who knows respect loyalty who knows to
respect
uh trust uh because today it's really
important to to have a trustful
partner from the other side and
during the covet and everything that
happened
and we we established this organization
and uh actually the the biggest one and
the the most important
uh organization in in whole region uh
because uh we have really uh good uh
connection uh as a country with the
with uae and during the caveat and uh
you know pandemic happened and what
happened with people and jobs and
everything
believe it or not but i started to
got emails and
messages on linkedin from the people
that i asked for my job in uae
that's where it comes together
yeah i love that sonia i have to say
that your journey
on one hand it's phenomenal it's it's
we've had
i've had a lot of non-linear journeys on
this show people that
are doing really extraordinary things uh
today and
looking back they now they can maybe
connect the dots and i think that going
back to how you're looking at your
experience in the united states
all the way back to the beginning of the
conversation i think it says a lot about
you know both your personality but and
your ability to reflect debrief and but
push forward boundaries
whether it's the boundary of you know of
going to the
to the arts to dramatic arts and and
proving yourself there or going
to the uae and proving yourself there i
i can't imagine and getting 500 you know
rejections if you
can even call them that and and then
proving yourself
going forward and doing such meaningful
work and i've i've been following your
work and it's just incredible what
you're doing both for the uae for
serbia for europe in general and and i
just love your energy so thank you for
taking the time to share this with me
and unfortunately we have to end now but
i have to ask the most important
question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
oh uh
describe myself in three words well
uh i'm a dreamer
believer and
self-confidence definitely i love that
sonny
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy
foreign